大家好,我今天给大家分享主题是来自腾讯的一个开源东校解决方案,撇计
首先介绍一下我个人的经历,我工作的前半段主要在游戏行业
低价公司是开心农场的开发商,后半段主要在短视频行业
目前就职于腾讯,主要负责音视频发布相关的一个中台建设
我们团队主导的音视频解决方案目前已经堆截服务了腾讯内外400家的
现在能看到吗?没问题,一切正常
我们团队主导的音视频解决方案
目前已经对接服务了腾讯内外400家的业务场景
今天要给大家分享的就是腾讯AVG OT下面的
一个开源组建撇计的东西解决方案
这是今天的一个分享大干
我将分为五个部分对PAG动效方案进行介绍
先来看第一个部分PAG的一个诞生背景
PAG主要是诞生在音视频编辑场景下的
可以看到这是一期微视的运营海报
里面包含有大量的视频动效素材
包括动画贴纸、转场特效
以及带天际和地理位置的
这些动效的智能文本
对音视频发布来说
这些动效素材的生产需求是远远不断的
并且对产量、三线速度以及视觉效果都有比较高的要求
视频动效的需求量很大
但是时间起来的成本并不低
传统的思路是设计师使用A1先设计好动效
然后导出视频demo
然后研发再来根据视频demo拆解动效组成
如果是不支持的特效能力
还需要单独排气进行开发
即使是已经支持的特效
也要发挥大量的时间
手动去还原各种的属性配置跟时间走
并且与设计师仿佛地去连调
确认这个还原度是否OK
那最后再由运营营验证素材
然后配置上线
这一套传统的流程
它有几个核心的痛点
第一是研发成本高
每一个动效
它都需要研发通过代码来还原
单独排期的特效
以及手工配置还原的过程
都需要大量的研发能力
持续的投入
而由于研发能力
大家都知道这个是非常有限的
支援也导致这个流程
它注定无法批量化生产素材
第二方面是生产周期很长
设计适合研发人员之间的连调成本非常高
效果还原度需要仿佈的学论
之前生产一个典型的视频模板
平均就需要研发投入五人天还原
才能够上线
这样就带来很严重的问题
就是很难跟上运营节奏
容易错过实施的乐点
第三是在视觉动效方面
效果会比较弱
A里面有很多复杂的效果
使用蠢蛋吗
反映起来是非常非常困难的
设计师只能不断的简化效果
也达到跟开发成本的一个平衡
导致最终上线的视觉效果都是打过折的
很难达到最开始的预期
那要彻底解决这些核心痛点呢
我们是需要一套自动化的素材生产通路
为了解决以上这些冬夏素材的
生产瓶颈和研发瓶颈
我们团内从2016年开始
就开发了一套
PSG的冬夏解决方案
下面我详细介绍一下这套方案
PAG的目标是降低或者消除动画相关的研发成本
打通设计时创作到素材上线的自动化流程
整套工作的由主要分为左边的A导出插件和桌面域狼工具部分
以及右边的SDK部分
A导出插件能够直接将设计师制作好的东西
要导出成PAG文件
经过桌面域狼工具的确认
再上线到中端
由PAG的SDK渲染成中销内容
可以发现左边的部分
我们实际上是不需要研发介绍的
我们将之前需要研发介绍的工作量
都转变成了自动化的工具
整套工作流完美解决了传统工作流的
三个核心的痛点
首先在研发成本方面
在PAG的东霄工作流里面
研发之后一次性介绍SDK的成本
而在后续整个的素材生产流程中
都无需研发能力的介绍
整套工作流不再数字于研发能力的瓶颈
就能够开放给更多的设计师使用
批量化的进行素材生产
第二在生产周期方面
由于砍掉了研发成本
对耗水研发跟设计的连挑环节也就不存在了
设计师可以所见及所得的生产素材
极大的缩短的素材的生产周期
之前提到的视频模板的平均生产耗水
可以从一周降低到四个小时
这样我们就可以实现快速响应运营乐点
第三是在视觉动效方面
PG的SDK目前已经完全还原了
一整个动销的渲染系统
揭露一次设计师可以充分利用AE动效的原子能力
组合出无限的视觉动效
不再需要因为代码还原成本的问题
而对效果上面去打折扣
可能前面介绍的还不太直光
这里有一个模板素材上线的一个视频演示
可以看到设计师在制作完模板后
只需要很简单的点击菜单里的导出选项
我们就可以得到一个撇计文件了
这不需要任何复杂的配置过程
导出的撇计文件双击就能够直接播放
而且浴缆工具里面还提供了
文本和占位图的替换编辑能力
可以直接看到替换
为用户素材后的整个的效果
在经过作为浴缆工具的整个的确认之后
设计师可以加撇计文件交付上线了
通过撇计的SDK
可以一次性地渲染到
几乎所有的主流平台上
这是目前我们支持的所有的平台
然后小程序也包含在里面
小程序跟卧本
PG方案雖然是當生在視頻編輯產品下,但同樣也適用於其他產品下的動效訴求。
這是到目前為止,PG的五個典型用場地,直播、禮物、UI動畫、貼紙、花枝、視頻模板和遊戲戰報,從左到右對編輯性的要求也是一次提高的。
目前微信視頻號裏面的直播就採用PG方案實現所有的禮物動效,也用戴了之前比較獲得西城南海的現場演唱會裏面。
UI动画这里掌握的Pig按钮
它是一个PAG做的可交互动效
支持编程控制进度 文本内容
整个动效文件的体积非常小
2K就可以实现这整个的效果了
然后中间的贴纸花字和视频模板
相信大家在各种短视频产品中
都已经非常熟悉了
这也就不对述了
其中PAG的视频模板
现在也已经大规模地
应用在了广告视频的生产中
最后一个游戏账报的场景
使用了pag提供的图成组合能力
可以从多个原则pag文件动态组合出一个知识硬的模板
有点相当于一个火字印刷的功能
这块目前已经应用在王者龙腰以及和平精英的高官史克的游戏战报里面
大家感兴趣的话也可以去各个平台上面去体验一下
目前在微信和手Q上面都有游戏战报相关的内容
含業裏面跟貼劑相似的解決方案
還有Rota跟SVGA
這三個方案背後其實存在一個比較有意思的共同點
最後我分享完PPT之後
我們可能也會展開聊一下這一塊
這三個方案他們的作者
都是從Fresh相關的含業出來的
都有這一塊的重頁背景
然後Fresh其實是歷史上
把研發跟設計師的工作流
打通了最位網上的一個平臺
但是从PC时代多录到移动端后
这就出现了彻底的一个断层
这三个方案其实都是在
将原先房屋的FASH工作流
复刻到移动端上面
一起在推动含业冬孝工作流的
一个持续往上
这三个方案除了荡绅场景的不同
目前PAG相比其他方案
在文件格式宣传架构A特性支持
运行编辑以及平台支持度上面
各个方面都根据有优势
相同的动画内容PAG导出的文件
只有其他方案一半以下的一个大小
额外还支持全部的AE特性导出
更丰富的运行室编辑接口
以及有对几乎所有主流平台的覆盖
相信经过前面刚的两节的一个讲解
大家对PAG方案解决的具体问题和应用场景
已经有一个大致的了解
那么在接下来的两节中
我将带大家深入到这个方案的技术细节里面
展示如何从头去打造一个
PAG东校方案的全过程
以及其中涉及到的重点基础挑战和难免
PKG方案到目前为止已经迭代了五年多
供经历过四个大版本
在1.0版本时
我们的主要需求是在视频上
迭较各种带动效的贴者和花日
并且在保留预设动效的前提下的提供
文本的编辑能力
但当时刚刚发布的落铁
并不满足以上的这些需求
除了那个文本无法编辑外
整个方案也没办法
用在视频编辑的产品下
因此我们从最底层开始实现了一套
类似游戏引擎的渲染价格
能够无分的跟视频渲染管线整合
并通过三期缓存的加购的这些设计
都是借鉴从游戏引擎里面来的经验
满足了极高的实施性的渲染需求
另外在这个版本中
我们花了最多时间的部分
其实还是在PSG文件格式
本身的一个设计上面
PSG的文件格式大量吸收
借鉴了Flasch的承受文件格式设计
並且針對AE的時間軸特點
做了進一步的極限壓縮
最終我們實現了
相同的動向內容
導出只有裸鐵一半左右的大小
而且但是解碼速度還平均
還快十二倍
PAG的1.0版本可以總結為
我們基本上全方位
實現了一個更好的裸鐵
但是在功能跟它對齊的情況下
性能文件大小和使用場景上
都更具有全面的優勢
當1.0版本的PAG
它本身跟裸鐵一樣
都是只能支持AE有限的使量特性导出
我们在那个迭代的过程中
很快就收到大量设计师的痛点反馈
很多的素材
它就需要不断的删剪
效果才能完成上限
这样会极大地限制设计师的上意发挥
于是我们在2.0版本里面
重点就引入了叫做BMP语和成像的
一个解决方案
并且比较创新地实现了
使量跟序列争的混合导出能力
从而在保留编辑性的前提下
又实现了所有AE特性的导出
从这个版本开始
才真正以上撇去彻底释放了设计师的生产力
另外在这个版本中
我们还引入了张卫图的概念来解决视频模板的需求
核心的原理其实就是
运行时将视频主帧的替换到指定的这个张卫图上面
然后由撇计文件来控制视频的画面
动效以及成绩的关系输出完整的内容
设计师在制作视频模板的时候
他只要很简单地添加一个张卫图
并把当成视频处理就行了
对它应用的任何的变化和特效
最终都会作用到替换后的用户视频
这样可以把模板的创意生产
完全交给设计师发挥
最终让照片或者视频模板这些应用场景
可以进入到一个工业化批量生产的时代
到PLG3.0的时候
我们在运行室编辑性方面
又遇到了新的一个业务挑战
在新出现的类似叫一键出片
跟游戏账报这些业务场景下面
模板它已经不再是单独的一个PAG文件了
而是引入了一个潜质位的分析过程
它会根据用户传入的视频内容
随即生成一个自身应能模板
2.0的当PAG模板
给这么说更像是一个密停作文
让用户传视频或者照片去填空
而3.0的模板它存在无线种可能性
就是设计师也没办法靠穷聚
没种可能性去生产收采
最佳的方式是生产
一个个小的PAG效果组件
然后运行时进行拼装组合
那基于这个目标呢
我们在3.0重点引入了图成渲染数的整个的编辑架构
那素材的最小控制单元
由单个的PG网件变成了
它里面的一个图成
那一个文件呢
它其实就是一个渲染数
它内部的每个图成
我们都可以愣意地增商改
我们提供了很好的
很完善的API去做这种事情
然后也可以把多个PG网件
组合成一颗新的渲染数
那同时每一个图成呢
都具有空间位置和时间位置的一个调整能力
经过这些的改造
新的接口不仅很好地满足了
类似《玩者仗报》这样的一个需求场景
也为海量的素材播放
提供了一个新的性能优化的可能
就不再需要给每个动效创建独立的一个上下文
都走齐皮皮渲染了
而是可以把他们组合在一起
然后一起共享一个上下文进行渲染
可以实现那种同频里面
大量动画素材的同频的国贩
然后整个的性能会有一个大幅的提升
在PG的前三个大版本的迭代功能中
大部分的业务痛点问题
其实都已经得到比较好的解决跟覆盖了
但我们始终还存在两个难以回避的痛点
首先是在SDK的包体方面
绝大部分的业务
它对包体都有很严格的要求
因为直接关心到增长它新的数据
有的业务甚至要求揭露后是零增量的
就说Sdk接进来
你不能让我的App最终变大
然后当然在4.0版本之前
由于PG它依赖的第二回头引擎
本身就占去了80%左右的包体
导致我们很难进一步优化
PG本身自己的代码量
其实只在这里面占了20%
另外在平台支持方面
因为我们3.0之前
十点零之前的时候一直都还没有补权
对卧宝平台的支持
到十点零的时候才去发布这种支持
核心的原因也是背后
斯基亚所带来的限制
所以我们希望通过
通过卧宝、三伯里加卧宝
GRO的技术来实现跨平台宣朗的一致性
确保卧宝端它没有能力层面的业格
当时斯基亚的卧宝、三伯里版本
存在包体巨大了
并且没办法访问
柳两期中文字体这些的缺陷
導致我們一直都沒有啟動握個板的支持
到4.0版本的時候
我們在上層能做的工作差不多已經都到極限了
不管是包體還是性能優化
然後想要繼續突破的
只能深入到渲染引擎層面徹底替換掉實地
所以我們在4.0裡面
花了當了一件非常大的事情
就是花了將近一臉半的時間
從頭時間了一套全新的純GPU的
後來那個繪圖引擎
我們叫TGFX
最終將貼近包體
只限降低了65%左右
并且将贴级的完整能力
不带任何阉割的扩展到了握个端
目前小程序也已经覆盖了
下面我会详细展开
刚刚提到的四个大版本的架构眼睛过程中
提到的几个关键的技术挑战点
先来看第一个技术挑战点
贴级是如何把导出的文件
大小能够做到相同的动画内容
做到楼点一半左右的那小
我们先来看一个AE动效文件
通常的组成是什么样的
它通常是这样就是一个层层包含的
一个塑状的结构
其中的那个时间走属性
是AE动效的最最基本单元
它控制了一个目标
只是随着时间走
应该如何变化的规则
AE动效的原理
其实就是无数个时间走属性
随着时间变化
然后构成了每个顺势的画面
这样的一个AE动效文件
我们应该如何把它存出起来
是最搞笑的
这里我们在设计之初
就定了三个核心的目标
要能够当文件交付
解码速度要更快
然后动效文件要足够的小
那当文件交付主要是要解决工作流
从文件传递的一个效率
你不然你带着很多的附件
这个对设计师用起来也很不方便
然后解码速度会影响手针的一个播放体验
那动效文件大小就更不用说了
除了结成用户的下载实产外
在很多APP中也直接关系到增长拉芯的效果
基于以上的目标
我们首先在选刑上面
就没有像罗铁一样的
采用了JSON那种制服串的方法
而是采用了二斤制的数据结构来存储动向内楼
因为二斤制的数据结构
能够非常方便的当文件集成任何资源
并且由于不需要像JSON一样
处理制服串匹配的问题
制服串匹配是非常慢的
解码速度可以快几十倍
而在压缩率方面
二金值数据结构可以跳过key的传统
这传统value
那这样也能够结成大量的空间
另外的我们还引入了这种
tag数据快的这种的结构
来解决二金值数据的向后结农性问题
每一个贴级稳件
它都有无数个互相独立的tag数据快组成
那扩展格是我们只要新增tag的
新增一种tag就行了
高版本的sdk可以识别
低版本所有的tag
低版本sdk遇到无法识别的tag
它就跳过读取
如果不是關鍵的信息
也可以正常的解碼不影響去了
比如那個Type
它記錄的信息是注視相關的信息
那做到這個程度
基本上已經滿足前面提到的三個目標了
但其實到這個程度
它也只是對齊了行業裡面
通用的虛略化法案的一個壓縮三線
在壓縮率方面
其實我們還有很大的空間
但進一步壓縮的原理
就是根據動效文件本身的特點
來跨越這個字節邊界來實現壓縮
极限压缩这里主要分享两个策略
核心就是充分利用A动效文件本身的特点
第一个策略是等于默认值我们可以无需存储
时间走储性是刚也提到是A动效的最最基本组成单元
通常情况下大部分时间走储性它都等于默认值
设立师只会改了几个储性
这里我们可以用一个标志位就跳过默认值的存储
我举个例子,像一个point的时间軸属性
它表示的那个坐标X1
每个图像都有这个东西
默认值我们要把它存下来的话
至少要8个字节
而如果我们用一个字节的标志围来跳过
这个默认值传组
当个属性就可以节省7个字节的空间
这个就非常可观了
那第二个策略是尽量
尽可能地去聚合相似的数据类型
我们在文件的每一个属性组里面
都会尽可能地把相似的数据
重新去排列
让它们聚合到一起
这样可以闹开字节对齐的问题
使用比特位来紧凑存储
例如中间的这一组数字
它经过重新排列之后
符号位的区域
你就可以一个比特一个比特的
把它压缩在一起
那就可以从四个字
本来要用四个字节去存储四个符号位
变成四个比特就行了
所以它们被可以压到一个字节的面去
内容的区域还可以利用
我们所有的内容它把它冲住到一起了之后
比如说全部都是同一个类型的
都是int类型的
我们就可以常考右边的
这个叫做连续整形书组压缩的这种算法
然后它可以用跨越字节边界的方法去存储它
然后存储最大只需要的实际的笔头位数
但这样平均可以节省一半以上的文件大小
那还有比如说是像辅典书的书组我们怎么弄呢
其实还是根据东校的一个稳定特点
我们遇到的大多数辅典数
它在实际的东校里面表示的
大部分都是屏幕上的做标
而是做标的精确度
其实要求不会那么高
我们是喊业里面有个通用的标准
就是20分之1是一个像素
在呈现上面
大家在呈现上面最小的一个精度
就能够达到视觉上面比较好的一个效果
所以我们其实可以用乘以20的方式
然后把所有辅典书转成Int
又可以回到前面整形数组
压缩的策略上面去
把它给平均减少
一半以上的文件大小
然后经过前面几个的压缩策略的生效
我们就可以把一个冬孝文件
尽可能压到最小
这里是一些
PG跟Rotter的冬孝文件大小的
文件对比数据
这两者都还是经过了
这份压缩之后再进行对比了
可以看到相同的冬孝内容
平均编辑只有裸铁文件56%的大小
如果这里不进行这一份压缩的话
这两个差距还会更大
下面再讲一下
渲染架构方面的优化
编辑是当生在视频编辑餐厅的
最初也是为了解决裸铁
它无法在视频编辑餐厅下使用的问题
我们在渲染架构上面
要如何设计才能让
这个新的动效方案
能够在视频编辑餐厅下
被完美的整合使用
PAG 渲染加购设计这里
我们一样在开始的时候
也定了两个核心的目标
就是最关键的要能够在视频合成中
五分的就整合进去渲染
然后另外在性能方面
要能够满足实质预览
整个流畅的需求
先说第一个目标
现代的视频编辑宽假
都是基于PU去做渲染的
它接受的输入必须是文利
才可以获得最高的性能
并且视频导出大多
它也都要运行在指线程
否则很直观就影响你的整个UI的交互
就会卡顿
那裸铁的主要问题就是它依赖了
平台相关的UI组件去开发
这样整体的它方案的开发成本会比较低
当然限制了也不能够就直接输出到文理上
也没办法运行在指线程里面
而贴纪的整道方案是
基于跨平台的设计家跟OpenQL
从最底层一直开发上来的
所以像文件解码到上層的图成渲染数
全部都是从底层一直开发到上层
所有平台都是实现的是统一套实际上的两代
虽然这种方式的开发成本会非常的高
但是所有端共享统一套代码
天然的能够保证跨端渲染的一致性
然后最关键的是能够直接渲染到
视频编辑框架提供的目标稳定上面
并且完美支持指线程的渲染
在解决了刚刚说的能不能的问题之后
我们其实还要考虑如何进一步的优化
在视频编辑的场景里面
对性能的要求是会非常非常严格
因为每一帧我们定型的会存在非常多的视频
要做编辑码以及各种的特效的处理
甚至还会卷入一些AI的东西
这个时候留给PAG的渲染时间本身就不太多了
你不然就会主宰整个的那个现成
就没办法时间流畅的一个预兰
因此我们要尽可能地把PAG的渲染性能
优化到几日来满足
士兵编辑实施越南的需求
第一个方向其实就是利用
素材存在静态区间的概念来优化
我们在PAG里面会充分地利用静态区间的特性
来跳过所有的重复会议
大部分的动销素材
实际上它并不是整个时间都在变化
或多或少都会存在一些画面静止的区间
而PAG在刷停的时候
如果遇到这些静态区域间
会直接返回上一阵的内容
然后自动跳过任何重复的会议
我们举一个极限情况下的例子
假设有一个一分钟的动作效果
但实际上全程都是精致的
那么它对撇计来说播放的时候
就是相当于一个静态直线
整个刷新过程都是零开销的
而在裸铁的那个同样的方案里面
它实现的会比较简单
它整个的刷新过程都是全量的开销
因为每周它都会清空屏幕去重新刷新
第二个方向就是利用空间换时间的实录
我们在PID里面设计一个三减缓存的价格
包含文件缓存、挥质缓存跟内罗缓存
由下至上它占用了内存量会一次提高
但是加出效果也是一直更加明显
在文件缓存的层面
我们将减满后的对象设计成了可复用的
那同一个动效文件你只需要减满一次
就可以被复用到无限个动效实力里面去炫耳栏
在那個繪製緩存層面的
我們緩存了每針的被塞取消
插值以及計算完的
是那個文本跟史量的數據
這裡還結合了
靜態區間的特點去優化這個緩存
比如說每個圖層
它如果存在靜態區間的話
都只緩存靜態區間第一針的數據
那後面的都是附用前面的
這樣就可以達到最少的內存
換來最大的一個緩存加速效果
最後在內容緩存層面的
我们会加一些内伦静态
但是非常复杂的图形缓存成文理
但是我们会在保证轻轻度的前提下去做缓存
只缓存最小的面积
例如一个500×500的一个动向
如果实际是按照50×50
你在按照50×50的Icon大脚在播放
我们也只会缓存50×50的面积
以上这些缓存它本身都是渐进式生产
就是你播到了的时候延迟到最后
然后它才会请求到它
那不会造成那个卡段
然后再结合那个静态区间的特点呢
它可以结成大量的那个重复计算
就刚刚说了静态区间我们只缓出低征
你不仅是结成了内存
而且后面的所有的这些差值的重复计算
我们都可以附用前面的结果
再来看看那个pg2.0版本的最最重要的那个更新
我们是如何让设计师在AE里面制作的所有东西都可以导出的
Rotate的方案其实一直到今天
今天都还是只支持纯实量的一个导出方式
实量导出方式是有优势
它优势就是玩键非常的小
并且可以运行是编辑动效的内容
但这种方式它注定无法支持所有的A特性
因为核心是说有很多的A效果
它在有装面显卡的情况下
都要走一个进度条路你才能预览
你想像这样的一些特效
它在移动端是完全不可能
从原理上就不可能做到实施渲染
这也导致了在实际生产的过程中
设计师用了很多第三方插件
用了很多很高级的一些粒子效果
这些复杂的动效
他都没办法用史量模式直接导出出来
这样会极大限制设计师的创意发挥
而传统的我们其实会有一种
叫区列针那个导出方式
但它带来的问题就是无法编辑
文件也相对会比较大
那贴纪法案的这些创新点
其实是将两者进行了完美的一个结合
支持史量跟区列针的混合导出
设计师可以主动标记出来
哪些图程需要使用序列帧导出
例如不需要编辑并且有复杂的动效的
而需要编辑的图程
继续使用简单的实量导出方式
从而实现支持所有A特性同时
又能保持运行时的编辑性
在实现混合导出之后
剩下的挑战就是
我们怎么要怎么样
才能够尽可能地去压缩序列帧的大小
就是文件大小对我们还是非常关键的
我们在PAG的内部
设计了一种叫做视频序列帧的格式
它充分利用了视频的极限证件压缩能力
另外选视频的格式
还有一个好处就是
它在运行时可以充分利用硬件加速来解码
获得更高的渲染性能
但它有一个很明显的缺点
它就不只是透明通道
当我们的解决方案社会
在导出的时候
加一张RGBA的截图
扩展成两倍大小的不透明图片
比如说左边放置RGBA内容
右边放置表示R法的回度图
最后在宣览的时候再合并回RGB的图片
从而实现透明通道的姿势
而在宣览的过程中
我们也没有像常规作法一样
就是先做外邮威到RGB转换
再叠加RGB通道的合并
而且是直接实现了各种
外邮威硬解格式的一次性上屏
利用之地硬的shade
在一次汇制中同时完成了
外邮威到RGB的转换
以及跟RGB通道的合并
当视频血液增热整个的汇制
都接近了那个像普通图片的上屏的性能一样
解决了当个视频设计的那个导出跟渲染的问题之后呢
我们还考虑上层的数据分装格式
PG没有使用标准的P4拢器作为视频帧的一个分装
而是设计了一个简化的数据结构
主要这里也还是出于性能优化的原因考虑
第一个方面呢是因为动效播放它本身是存在水晶性的
我们需要一致性拿到所有的关键证列表
才可以做到精确的判断
当前这个时候是否需要seq
是否需要重置减碼器
当然要从标准的MP4笼器里面获取关键证列表
这个耗时会非常的高
几百毫秒成绩级别的
那另一方面
视频血液证本质上
它还是代表的是一个动效
一直也存在前面提到过的
静态区间的那个概念
那在导出的时候
我们利用自定义的这个数据结构
就很容易把靜态区间相关的数据
根据靜态区间的数据来插入这个关键帧
并把靜态区间的数据写到这个指定义数据结合了一切
这样它虽然对文件大小
最终文件大小没有任何的变化
但是对渲染性能会有很大的影响
这样在渲染的时候
我们就可以直接跳过那些不必要的解码器等待了
你即使是一帧空的数据
你闯个解码器
它也是还有一个固定的
硬件解码器有一个固定的主塞的
我們就從工具鏈一直到宣覽這裏面
做了一個完整方案的打通
然後整個的做了一個流程上的一句話
例如右邊這個綠字
這個俄羅斯方塊的視頻模板
它們一個方塊宣覽都是一個靜態的圖層
當時使用了死量不知死的效果
因此設計師就會把標記成BMB與合成
然後導出了一個類似就是全時長
都是靜態的視頻學業徵
那這種情況它也比較常見
但是经过刚刚那个优化呢
我们直接能够提升百分之九九性的
不然所有耗时都是卡在了
卡在了这个这个那个硬件接码
记得等待上
最后可以看一下我们前面提到
就是那个在压缩子上面的努力
那结果是说各种训练争方案
呃尾间大小对比就在这个图里面
相比传统的就是图片训练争呢
我们的我们自己那个
这种的视频训练争呢
能够轻松压缩到百分之一点几的大小
前面在4.0版本的那个迭代过程中
我们也提到过
一直还没有解决包体跟Wobb平台式配两个的痛点
那背后的主要原因都是因为依赖了谷歌的SKR回头引擎
下面是分享一下
我们是如何替换掉SKR引擎
并取得包体跟性能的进步突破的
首先看一下为什么不继续使用SKR
目前谷歌开源的SKR2D混度库
它是含义里面已经是事实标准了
多年来几乎没有实质性的替代方案出现,像Chromo, Firefox, Fart, Adobe的鞋带软件,乃至Android系统的UI,都在在基于Skiya做文本和实量的会议者。
Skiya本身是一个维护了近20年的方案,也存在非常大的历史包袱,很难满足PG对包体跟性能进步的优化的诉求。
而在包体方面,我们虽然已经针对Skiya做了非常多的定制和裁减,但是它依然占据了PG3.0版本的80%左右的包大小。
而且也没有办法进一步再拆建了
在性能方面
由于SKIR需要兼容历史遗留的CPU汇准模式
在API的暴露上面
它相对就会比较保守
很多针对现代GPU汇制管线
可以进一步在优化的接口
它都没有暴露出来
另外由于SKIR是针对UI这种
随机汇制需求产击设计的引擎
它内部做了大量的缓存
来确保随机渲染的性能
但是对于动效这种
我们这种可预测的渲染模式
它其实没有很好的一个优化
那会导致额外的就是浪费了很多的内存
为了彻底突破包体和性能的限制
我们花了将近一年半的时间
制养了一套非常轻量的纯GPU的绘图引擎
TGFX完成了对SKR的梯化
下面看一下TGFX具体做了哪一期的优化
首先在包体方面
我们最终实现了以400K左右的包体
覆盖了SKR近两兆包体的绝大部分功能
核清到优化策略的主要有两点
第一是我彻底抛弃了CPU渲染管线
因为现代的硬件几乎已经不存在没有GPU的设备
即使像服务端这种特殊的场景
通过SWIFI Shader来模拟得得到的性能也会让你很意外了
反而可能会比你自己去写CPU相关的渲染会来得更快
然后单身的SKR由于历史原因
一直同时支持
一直同时包含了CPU跟GPU两条绘子管线
并且它的GPU渲染管线是重度依赖CPU的部分的
导致他们是没办法单独使用它的GPU渲染管线
我们在TGFS里面就特地解决了这个偶和的问题
打造出了一个纯GPU的绘土引擎
这里就是节省了大概一半左右的包体
第二个点是最大化的去利用平台端类似的所有能力
例如像图片解码、字体解析、实量三个化等等
这些都会优先使用系统原则的接口
来替代内置第三方库打包第三方库的一个策略
以文本的识量的三个化为例
在L字上,我们会直接使用系统提供的Core Graphics
文本方面就利用起来CoreTest
而在其他平台上面
没有这些支持了我们才
比如说服务器,我们再签入Free type
那虽然是增加了不同平台的适配的工作量
但是包体确实也得到了一个极致的优化
而在刚讲的包体
我们TGFX在医用性方面
也做了一些改进
尤其是Skiya没有的Device跟Windows系统
Skiya实际上提供了GPU的渲染管件
使用起来门槛还是比较高的
主要存在两个问题
第一是Skiya只实现了挂平台渲染的部分
所有跟平台相关的仕途
桥接以及上架纹的出手化
都需要用户自己来处理
这会导致用户正常用起来
Skiya的GPU模式
需要对每个平台编写大量的适配单码
除了工作量比较大以外
最主要问题是
这里面是兼容性的一个重载区
你要处理大量的类似iOS中
推到后台之心OpenGL
会夸掩这种特殊的问题
第二个点是Skeler并不帮你保证
现场安全或者删下稳的切换
默论都是调用方式自己出源
他们真的很专注
就是只做最里面的渲染的部分
但是绝大部分刚刚结束到Skeler的用户
它其实并不清楚这个坑点
Skeler也没有显示说明过
按照它普通的方式
你就接入使用
就很容易造成大量的显存
泄露已经难排查
随即夸去
它经常会在没有删下我的情况下
不小心就把你GPU支援给示范掉了
但是在TGFX里面
我们提供了网上的DIY-S跟Windows系统
可以把你把这些问题一次性的都屏蔽掉
你只要按照统一的模式进行调用就行了
我们也在API上做了限制
你只能以这种方式进行调用
所以会非常的安全
所有平台相关的复杂度
你都可以不用关心
然后即使没有非常之深的GPU的渲染经验
你也可以很容易的用起来
这个API不会产生大量的
很难查的夸取问题
然后再讲一下
就是说在性能跟架构的优化方面
点可能会比较多了
我们就快速过一下
TGF还做了哪些额外的一些优化
左边第一
我们默论开启了Hardware 8 Pro的支持
来全面提加速
稳利的一个提交
这里的重点是其实用了运气计时反射的机制
来彻底解决了设备兼任务性的问题
只要设备上面设备或者系统存在这块能力
我们就会自动开启
然后左边第二个
因为没有兼容CPU模式的一个包含
我们直接就暴露PASS对应的GPU高速缓存
这样可以让业务有能力
直接缓存最关键的GPU对象
避免每次重复会设PASS
都是重复去深圳GPU的缓存
左边第三个,TGFX彻底改进了SKR的GPU对下的管理模型
所有的GPU对下都可以在愣意的线程进行示范
等到管理上下文激活的时候,它才会真正仔细清理
这个也避免了前面刚刚提到的线程安全的一些问题
在SKR里面经常出现的随机快捷和内存泄露的问题
都可以被这个模式给解决掉
然后右边第一个我们在TGFX的接口设计上面
约束了调用方在解码完图片的时候
只会缓存GPU的纹理部分
这样理论上
全局可以直接降低一半左右的内存占有
避免像SKR里面
它的所有的图片总是先解到CPU上
然后再提交到纹理
然后两份的内存都一直站在那边
右边的调整
TGFX会把管理缓存的主动权
更多都会交给上层的业务
让上层来进行化的管理
这样不会像史基亚一样的
为了优化随机绘制的这种的场景
就在内部产生过多的垄鱼缓帧
而史基亚现在做法相对比较粗暴的
只是通过设计上线来触发
打到上线才会清理
所以你经常会画着不张内存
为什么涨上去了
一直也是放不掉
然后最后一个就是
TGF在全平台都实现了
默论字体的读取能力
也包括从浏览器里面独有其默认的中文字体
这个也就解决了Skiar的Wobber版本
在这一块的缺陷
不然的话,我们渲染中文还要下载三宝兆的字体包
以上这些其实都还是TGF作用的优化的一部分
更多的细节也欢迎大家到Github的开源代码中参考去研究
TGF发现就在那个贴近的仓库下面
我们随后也会把二维码相关的链接发出来
最后来看一下整体的优化成果
再我们把SKIA彻底替换为TGF会主引擎
之后,PG-10.0版本的包体
整体平均都下降了65%左右
并且使量圈碗性能还提升了60%左右
整体的优化可以看出来是非常显著的
后续我们也正在推动
TGF作为一个独立的常固开源
我们会持续往上
并把它打造成一个偷用的2D会图引擎
为行业去提供SKIA之外的
另一个齐量化的一个选举项
最后做一下那个PG的总结
有没有掌管吧
PG方案呢
当生在最复杂的视频编辑场景下面
虽然是当生在这个视频编辑场景里面
但它也能够很好地去挽足
其他各种场景下的动向需求
它所提供的所经济所的桌面
工具和AE插件的能够
一键加设计师的创意导出
成PG5关键
也通过SD一个快速渲染
到几乎所有的主流平台上
整套公众有能给业务带来了三个方面的核心价值
第一是去研发成本
素材生产环节它无需研发借路
节省了大量的研发能力和调整反攻的成本
研发只需要揭露一次SDK的成本
那后续设计师就可以独立的完成素材的生产上限
也避免了最耗时的研发跟设计师的连调环节
最终将素材生产相关的研发成本大幅的降低
第二在公园化生产方面
由于不再受制到研发能力的瓶颈
那素材生产可以扩大到更多的设计师进行
批量化的生产
再加上着迷效率工具在效果预览
和性能检测上的应用性
设计师可以所见及所得的生产素材
最终那视频模板平均生产耗时中
一周可以降到4个小时
实际上快速想运热点
第三是无线的AE动效
PG SDK已经完全还原AE的整个动效系统
并且支持史量跟训练者的混合导出
你知道揭露一次
所以是可以附用貼記經過五年級的A東校原子能力
組合出無限的視覺東校
再也不用因為代滿還原成本的問題
對效果打折扣
來看一下貼記開源方面到目前的成果
貼記是今年38年1月10號正式開源的Github
目前已經得到了2300多個STAR
然後郭寶已經累積上線了46篇的文檔教程
大家可以到我們官網貼記點二的
咱們就訪問一下
那不管是设计师
还研发方面的教程
都是比较全面的
然后我们团队日展
对接了2000多个持续增长的设计师
跟研发的用户群
整体在里面的提问
还有火焦度都是很高的
然后最新也开辟了一个论坦的
一个板块
然后只要是有问题
在上面有问必答
而是DK目前已经接入服务了
腾讯内外400家的产品业务
就今年的增长还是非常的快的
我们刚开源的时候
其实只有40个左右
腾讯内部的产品业务
然后已经发了10多倍了
其中这些400个人的产品业务
就包括很多头部的应用
包括像微信、手机QQ、王者龙
腾讯视频、QE音乐等头部的APP
然后外部的有像B帐、小红书
知乎、豆磅、京东这些的产品
也都已经在使用高度的在使用PAG
就整个PAG整套的方案
其他稳定性已经经过了海洋用户的持续验证
最后是讲一下那个展望的部分
过去一年多了
我们团队的主要经历都投入到了
PAG 4.0和玄机渲染疫情的这块的开发
升级上面
目的也是为了后续整个PAG方案能有更高的一个天花板
接下来我们的中心会主要聚焦在四个方向上面
首先会开始继续补权更多的AE特性支持
前面提到这里可能大家会有疑问了
前面提到我们是支持所有AE特性导出的
但其实要解释一下
就是所有AE特性导出依靠的是BMP月合成的能力
但是用那个方式导出出来的文件
它是每办法运行是编辑的
所以我们围绕可编辑的图成
还是继续要补权能够使量方式导出的AE特性导
其次是会继续往上我们的工具链
重点是会推出那是图成级别的性能分析工具
这样可以帮助设计师快速地定位素材的性能热点在哪里
高效的完成性能调优
不用交给研发你测试一下
告诉我这个还得优化
它自己就能够用工具把它时间置入的优化了
然后是提起来是框架的持续的往上跟点带
继续会增加更多的渲染后端支持
我们现在已经
地域OpenGL把所有平台都实现了一遍了
那么接下来我们可能会把
紧接下来就会把Metal跟Walker这些硬件图链接口也都适配一下
最大化的去发挥现代GPU硬件宣传的性能
最后呢
我们这期也在也在搭建一个动效素材的一个一个社区
然后呢
希望有这样的一个动效素材的这样的一个社区
能够帮助一些企业快速地出达
海量的这种商用素材跟优势的设计师之人
最后再放上一些贴级相关的资料
大家如果感兴趣的话,可以进步了解
只要扫描中间的那个公众号二维码
那边是会有所有的资料跟链接的汇总路口
那我那个PVD的主体的部分就分享到这里
然后谢谢大家
OK,那个,谢谢东哥
好,那我停止,停止一下分享
好的,好的,OK
ok 呃内容确实是很干货哈就说实话我看到直播间有很多朋友在发就是听懂了
但是我不知道你们是不是真的听懂了我反正是没听懂啊
当然我觉得这个也是在预心内啊
因为毕竟是花这么长时间去打造的一个一个解决方案
不可能说是通过呃一个小时你就能把它完全听明白
但我觉得动格的这个分享更多的是说带大家去了解这样的一个方案
知道他的一些优势到底是什么
那后续的话因为本身是开源的嘛
所以我觉得大家应该是在这个分享之后
去花更多的精力去看一看这个整个PAG的原码
然后去更系统化的做一些学习
对吧
刚刚在那个直播间我看到有人在问
一个学来已经说是开源的
它是开源的
整个TGL为什么我快现在没有独立的仓库
就在LivePAG的那个开源常库里面
刚才那个那个二维码
你们去收或者直接收那个公众号
叫PAG动效
然后这个公众号上面会可以获取到
那个github的开源常库的地址
然后也欢迎大家觉得这个项目比较好的
欢迎大家给我们加个十大
谢谢没问题没问题
然后我觉得因为我们现在其实
每一期活动
其实给每一个讲师都是有专属的群的嘛
今天其实大家可以通过右下角
加入我们就是动物哥的这个专属的分享群
然后大家后续
我估计后面应该有些资料也会发在群里吧
大家可以在这个群里面
比如说如果大家在看着看项目的时候
有一些问题啊
其实也可以在群里面直接跟动物哥做交流
对不对
嗯就刚刚那个PPT其实嗯
会偏向概括一点
然后有很多的细节展开了
其实就太多了
我们可能迅速有这个问题
讲到这个程度
就是大家如果感兴趣的话
后续也可以在交流区域里面
继续问我一些问题